[Music]
for our series of the dish we are
looking at the cuisine of afghanistan
and how many recipes have been passed
down from generation to generation
family to family mother to daughter now
there's one couple with roots in
afghanistan updating that tradition
in a series of successful restaurants
around washington d.c the maz rohr
family decided to put
women
front and center jan crawford shows us
now the results it's a powerful message
about food and female empowerment
when sophia mesrier is making her famous
leaking scallion dumplings she smiles
i just love it because it reminds me of
my childhood it's my all-time favorite
dish
a childhood that began in afghanistan
before her family fled to the united
states after the soviet invasion when
the country was a cosmopolitan
celebration of cultures
my mother when she would make this dish
my favorite part was to do this oh
really yes
sit around the dining room table and we
would stuff the
wrappers
the delicate leek and scallion dumplings
are just one of the classic dishes
featured in sophia and husband omar's
washington dc area afghan restaurants
which they started as a way to share
their country's sophisticated cuisine
every african restaurant you would go to
is just kebab kebab kebab
which is not the tradition it's not
traditional there's so much more there's
so much more to afghan food food
influenced by the many cultures that
formed afghanistan
food that's going to be coming from
central asia you know from china
india
the persians so it's a mixture of of
everything this food is like afghanistan
a combination of cultures
and different ethnicities and
backgrounds all coming together in like
a beautiful harmony which country that
you can go to or which
nation you could go today you could get
a rice dish that's gonna have raisins in
there that's gonna have carrots in there
that's gonna have almonds walnuts
meat pistachios
today afghanistan is anything but
harmonious
and seeing it return to taliban control
led the musr to make a statement last
fall that went well beyond food
omar decided to step back from the
operations and put the women his wife's
sister and his two oldest daughters in
charge i said listen the only way to do
a change or to make a statement is you
have to
from inside to do something not through
words not through anything but through
action
what was the statement that you were
trying to make them women can do
anything oldest daughter talia is the
new manager of bistro arakasiya running
all the restaurants day-to-day
operations amman is manager in training
at the mclean location sometimes people
ask me for the manager and i'm like well
i am the manager
what does it mean to you to kind of be a
part of this statement that you're
making oh it makes me feel good that
they think that i can manage a
restaurant and run a restaurant i want
to be ceo of the restaurants and just
learn how to do everything
the critically acclaimed restaurants the
women now in charge continue to expand
locations with plans to open a fourth
restaurant in the area they attribute
their success to the customers and the
recipes that span generations from one
mother to the next i mean i learned this
from my mother so
that's how she made it that's how i made
it and
that's how i'm teaching
others to make it
and now passing again to the next what
is your dream for your
your daughters
as they grow up
to know who they are that's all i just
want them to to to know that they can do
anything they want to do they can run a
business they can be a ceo better better
what's your dream for their futures for
them to you know be confident believe in
themselves
be kind human beings
you know it's just also it's not just
about them it's about everyone and for
all those other girls needing to hear
you can do it jan crawford cbs morning's
mclean virginia
[Music]
bravo you know my favorite line of that
piece came from omar yeah what'd he say
vlad omar said when she said what is the
statement you're trying to make that
girls can do anything yes
women can do anything i like that as
well but i also like what he's like it's
all kebabs kebabs
i like that too different menu there
like that you're lucky watching the dc
area because that looks very good it
does look very nice jan crawford yes
indeed jan